[Music]
good evening St Paul it's your city news
at 5 I'm Jamie throner and I'm Marcy wit
Church winter weather advisories are in
effect across central Minnesota tonight
with more on that weatherman Isaac
Labuda Isaac thanks Marcy a major system
is zipping across the region outside
temp right now 8° but it feels like 20
below Jamie well stay off the roads if
you can folks lots of reports of black
ice woo you got to watch out for that
dangerous black ice it's transparent and
sneaky hard to see black ice that's
right Marcy keep your loved ones safe
and warn them to stay off the street
tonight because of menacing life robbing
black black ice hi
Dick we have Channel 17's field reporter
Darren hemper with more Darren
[Music]
yeah I'm standing out here at historic
Ramsey Hill where there are currently no
cars on the street due to uh hazardous
driving condition